[Music]
special planting days were recently held
at silver stream Reserve as part of
Martinique eat a taco local members of
the RSA joined with council staff to do
Darko forestry New Zealand the silver
stream reserve advisory group and other
volunteers to plant 660 Kanaka seedlings
over two days
mustn't forget Flint and a bit of soil
on top Marta D kita Darko is a
partnership between Tod Darko forestry
New Zealand and local communities to
plant trees to recognize the service of
men and women of the New Zealand Defence
Forces and mark the 100-year anniversary
of the end of the first world war it's
part of a wider government initiative to
plant 1 million trees over the next 10
years the trees have been planted in a
grid to represent soldiers standing in
formation in the future seating will be
installed to create a beautiful space to
set and reflect the plantings are just
one small part of the Silverstream
reserve restoration project which aims
to return approximately 52 hectares to
native planting over the coming decades
and just the next year alone volunteers
and the council are hoping to plant
2,000 additional trees
[Music]